thank you thanks thanks thank you for
clapping appreciate they told me in the
back that they are recording this thank
you
alright let's get to the issues I I
think little people deserve equal rights
I do I do
yes I think it's time little people be
treated equally it's 2016
he had everywhere I go separate drinking
fountains and that joke gets applause I
feel like I'm starting a movement yes
you should you should never have sex at
Olive Garden when you're there your
family
so I live flannel cuz I'm pretty much
for a lady yeah I do
yeah we're left flannel makes me look
like the brawny man if they made a weak
paper towel there's some off-brand can't
pick up [ __ ] paper towel picture of me
in the mountains like I don't want to be
in the mountains doing well out flannel
my friend was like Brad the nineties
called and I say no they don't text
little a landline humor it's gotta be
it's gotta be frustrating being a
chester the cheetah you know he's he's a
mascot for Cheetos but he has perfectly
white fingers
because the jokes like that I get
offered weed a lot I really smoke weed
but I don't want to be rude to people
you know feel bad because we're being
generous that's a nice thing like I
found the most polite way you could
decline someone sweet it's just to say
nah I'm a cop so there's this movie
theater I I go to back home that Reese
shows old movies which is cool but they
need more room on their marquee they
need more space on that sign
like I can't describe the emotional
rollercoaster I went on during the two
seconds I thought gremlins Fight Club
was a movie by LIC gremlins fight club
that movie would have so many rules
so no more heroes you guys that's no
more heroes I'll Cogan Bill Cosby no
more heroes like like I love pee-wee
Herman I think he's a national treasure
I love him yeah someone told me he had a
scandal many years ago apparently he got
caught masturbating in a movie theater I
don't blame him for that I don't blame
him everything in his house had eyes
[Applause]
so so dragons you know
dragons breathe fire it'd be fun
watching one try to cool down soup I I
did that joke at a show in time and this
guy came up to me afterward he was like
that joke you do about dragons I said
yeah and he said fire doesn't burn a
dragon's mouth
why would soup
[Applause]
but whoa